a small gesture of thanks
one of the many agnieszka sophia shaq
has experienced since she took ukrainian
refugees into her home in poland
12 people now live in a space normally
meant for a family of four
[Music]
normally we'd extend this table at
christmas now it's pulled out all the
way all the time it's like it's always
christmas but at least this way we have
room for everyone
when war broke out in neighboring
ukraine agnieszka offered to
help wanted to make this room available
to three people but then in the middle
of the night a driver arrived with eight
people
the children were coughing and the women
started crying because they didn't want
to be split up
[Music]
as the war continues that act of
kindness has become a permanent solution
her family's exhausted
for two months now i haven't known what
it's like to come home to peace and
quiet
and perhaps we need that to start
getting back to normal
her sister and a friend arrived from
western ukraine with five children
they feel helpless and very
uncomfortable about it
this is their life
their family
they're used to being together
suddenly having eight more people around
is very hard
i'm even ashamed that aniesca and her
husband pay for all of our expenses
they buy everything the food and
everything we and the children need
to help the families that take in the
refugees the polish government plans to
make monthly payments of around 250
euros for each person they accommodate
but so far agnieszka has not received
anything yudmila tries to earn a little
something as a cleaning lady but can't
afford a place of her own
i have three children but even if i only
had myself to support
it would be very tough for me
many ukrainian refugees are in similarly
dire straits
they came to warsaw's national stadium
to register they're thankful for the
warm welcome but worry about their
future
i don't know what to do unfortunately
there is no work to be had here
poland has taken in lots of refugees
feeds them and keeps them warm
but there are just no apartments and no
jobs i want either to stay in poland and
get a job
or go to germany and find work there
you can't just sit around all the time
doing nothing people here give us their
last scent
yesterday for instance a woman donated
over a thousand dollars to our lodgings
they help a lot with everything we're
living here at their expense
rafael tamala has also been busy helping
ever since the war broke out he lets 20
ukrainian women and 40 children live at
his hostel in warsaw for free but he
also hopes for assistance from the state
you have enough strength and resources
for two more weeks
we're financing this from our own
private means because we haven't
received any financial help
we used to rent out rooms but we're not
taking any money from the refugees
with summer on the way many hotel owners
are faced with a dilemma let the
refugees stay on or take in paying
guests
given the expenses the polish state is
facing warsaw is hoping for more
financial aid from the eu
the european union's decision to provide
funding for refugees involves large sums
of money but it's still just a drop in
the bucket
it's very little
from the polish government's point of
view it would be important to set up a
fund to administer such it on behalf of
the eu and cover the needs of refugees
although she'd be glad to see at least a
little money soon agnieszka sobjershak
doesn't regret helping refugees
what's most important is that they don't
have bombs raining down on them we don't
need luxury
but with so many people here i must say
more aid is needed this is a bit much
but it's definitely been worth it
it seems most poles still feel the same
way
and like their ukrainian guests they
hope the war won't last much longer